this episode of the minimalists podcast
is brought to you by the letter R for
Ryan me cuz that's who's doing the
podcast today enjoy the show
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
hello everybody and welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less
I'm Ryan Nicodemus and I am half of the
minimalists welcome to episode number 16
we're doing this one similar to how we
did episode number 14 where instead of
Josh hosting it by himself and answering
questions it'll be me answering
questions and hosting it by myself today
we're gonna chat about what we're gonna
chat about a lot of things we're gonna
talk about my wardrobe we're gonna talk
about procrastination we're gonna talk
about all sorts of subjects but before I
get into that I just want to do a quick
reminder about our documentary if you
have not got tickets yet this is really
kind of your last chance because if some
of these screenings aren't tipped they
won't show so you can't wait until the
last minute to purchase a ticket so a
lot of these events are one-night only
special events since that's the case I
encourage you to get your tickets ahead
of time go to minimalism film calm and
then click on see the film all right
let's go ahead and get into our
voicemails our first voicemail is from
Kristin in Seattle I experienced issues
with wanting to minimize the amount of
social activities they do but at the
same time I'm struggling with that whole
FOMO or fear of missing out I feel like
I don't get very much value added from
doing all the different types of social
groups at the same time I still struggle
because I want to explore I want to go
out meet people on the time you
things but every time I definitely try
out all these different activities I am
not getting burned out really fast and
it just makes me seem like a flaky
person or someone who cannot I came into
groups do you have any advice on someone
wanting to explore new friends and get
new experiences without burning yourself
out or what you know if you can commit
to anything if you're trying out too
much all right Kristin that that's a
good question
how do you minimize your social
activities but still go out and meet
people and still associate with others
well I can tell you right now that you
definitely do need to make a change you
said it yourself you're feeling
overwhelmed you're not finding a lot of
value in all of this Association so I
certainly would agree with you that yes
something needs to change you need to be
more deliberate with your choices when
it comes to going out associating with
others going to social events I know
that I certainly have struggled with
this I I am a big extrovert I love going
out and hanging out with people but
sometimes I will over commit I will
double booked myself I've ran into a lot
of a lot of problems with trying to do
everything at once and certainly there
is that fear of missing out that that
all of us have
I think I'll talk about that first about
the fear of missing out you know we're
all missing out on 99.9% of everything
right now everyone who is listening to
this podcast right now is missing out on
everything else that is going on in the
world so there are certainly things that
we feel like we might be missing out on
but even if we get to do those things
there are so many other things that
we're not able to do so that's that's
would be my first first piece of advice
is just realize that every decision you
make every every piece of time that you
that you use you are missing out on
everything else at that exact moment so
really the question isn't what am I
missing out by not going out on this
Wednesday night or this
Thursday night maybe the question is is
how can my time best be used right now
and if you're like me and if you're a
huge extrovert I can tell you the first
step for me was getting comfortable with
myself I would go out and see movies by
myself go and have meals by myself I
would really go out of my way
to do this I would schedule time by
myself to to really get comfortable with
that and I still am very uncomfortable
with it
but I am much better at being with
myself and I can still get a lot of
things done still be productive by being
by myself it's funny I feel like I used
to in the old corporate world it was
always hey let's go to a coffee shop and
do some email together or hey let's
let's sit in a conference room and talk
this stuff out together and that's that
is typically how I approach most of my
work and I can tell you now that I have
found found it comfortable being by
myself it's a much more productive if
I'm if I'm doing those things alone so
first I would say get comfortable with
who you are and in being with yourself
go out of your way to change your state
by doing things that you typically
wouldn't do if you're typically going
out and partying on Friday and Saturday
night well go out and party on Friday
night and then on Saturday night try
something else
try something different the other thing
I would suggest to is schedule those
times that you want to be social pick a
number of times that you want to go out
each week if that's six nights a week
great that that's the number for you for
me I probably couldn't go out six nights
a week I would be too exhausted in the
mornings eventually if I was going out
every single single night but but
schedule each outing schedule each time
that you have with your friends and
family or coworkers or networking groups
or whatever it is schedule that out and
don't stray off that schedule so just to
kind of sum that up for your christen
start with learning how to be
comfortable with yourself make sure that
you're changing your state at some point
each week doing something different and
make sure that you're utilizing your
schedule and you're sticking to that now
inevitably
will happen you'll have your week
planned out and something will come up
the next night you've got to treat your
schedule like gospel now if it's an
emergency I certainly understand where
you would vary from that schedule or
maybe it's a really really amazing
opportunity where you're going to get
this big promotion or whatever I know
there are reasons there are valid
reasons out there that will make you
very firm your schedule but I'll tell
you there aren't very many reasons very
many good reasons I should say that that
should give you permission to vary from
your schedule so we're going to go ahead
and give you a copy of essential Kristin
I think you'll enjoy that book Josh and
I wrote a bunch of essays and kind of
compiled it in this but we talked about
the fear of missing out we talked about
scheduling and we talked about how to
change your state so I think that that
book will help you out all right let's
move on to our next voicemail from
Cortney my boyfriend he loves to buy me
things he's a great gift giver and it
gives him great joy to give me things
but we've brought in arguments over this
before amazing I don't need things and
him expressing that Nick isn't meaning
and purpose to give them especially
upsets and if it's a holiday
participating specifically my birthday
and I ask I notice his gifts always are
really wonderful and I love them a lot
but there are things I never knew I
needed until he give them to me and then
I become attached to more things so how
do you navigate the balance of
respecting both parties in that is right
to give and my right not to receive my
other question pertains to his family
and I know earlier in podcasters talked
about gift-giving as being a ridiculous
love language but my boyfriend and his
family has taken that on as theirs his
parents loved to buy me gifts that they
buy me things that I don't like or that
don't fit me and in the last episode you
talked about as a gift giver feeling
more offended by someone who is
disingenuously accepting exists they
will enjoy rather than the bummed out
feeling of the person turning down the
gift straight up
and so if someone's expressing their
love and joy to you by giving you a gift
how do you turn it down respectfully
because I found that when someone is
giving me a gift and saying this is I
got this specially for you and when
they've gone out of their way to do that
for me it's really hard to look at them
and say that you don't like it or don't
want it for some of the things I have
taken them back to stores I've gotten
cash or credit for that and that has
added value to my life but for the stuff
that I can't do that with I'm just
trying to figure out how to be
respectful about it Courtney Wow
that is certainly a tough situation to
deal with I know there are a lot of
people out there who get a ton of gifts
that they don't want whether it's for
them or their kids or what it may be you
know first I would I would have a
conversation with your boyfriend I'm
sure you've talked to him before but but
try to make it you know if a very
serious conversation that really helps
find a balance between this this this
gift giving and gift receiving and I
would start the conversation out with
something like you know honey I love you
very much and I really appreciate having
you in my life and without you my life
would not be nearly as great as it is
right now and I want to talk to you
about something that it's not really
easy to talk about about all the gifts
that you've been giving me and a lot of
these I do find value in but but some I
don't and I don't want to hurt your
feelings and just pick and choose what
gifts you give me but I would like to
find some type of balance between the
two of you getting me things that I
enjoy and me having to hold on to things
that I don't find value in or or don't
use so maybe we could start gifting each
other experiences or maybe we could
start gifting each other consumables or
maybe we can go way out of our way to
find something besides a physical item
to gift one another during these special
times during the year
anniversaries Christmas I mean
personally I
find find it obligatory to give a gift
on a holiday I give gifts when I feel
like giving them I've just brought out
my whole family out to Montana to visit
I got my grandma a plane ticket for her
birthday even though her you know I
didn't buy the plane ticket on her
birthday I didn't give it to her on her
birthday it was more of a she wanted to
pay me for it and I'm like hey why don't
I just call this your your birthday gift
and she was like yeah that'll be great
so there are certainly ways that you
guys can find a balance between gift
giving and gift receiving by just having
a very very serious conversation about
how you want to want to proceed in the
future it's not a matter of don't buy me
any more gifts as much as it is let's
change the way you give me gifts and
then with your with your family I mean
that's the I would encourage you to have
a similar conversation with them you
know something along the lines of I love
you guys very much I really appreciate
having you and you love me too right
yeah of course we love you and I really
want you guys to be happy and you want
me to want me to be happy too right yeah
of course we want you to be happy
Courtney well if that's the case then I
really really need you guys to support
me with with not accumulating a lot of
things and have the same conversation as
see if they can gift you give a gift you
a gift of their time or an experience or
I mean I have given my parents gifts
before of hey I'm gonna pay your
mortgage payment this month or I don't
even tell them I just go to the bank and
make a mortgage payment for them I mean
that's that's a it's a big cost I'm sure
not everyone can afford to pay their
parents mortgage payment I did that back
in the corporate world only you know
paid it once or twice but but my point
is is that there are very creative ways
to give gifts without giving a physical
item and you know when it comes to the
whole gift giving as a love language I'm
so I'm sorry guys but money does not buy
love
things does not buy love money and
things they're not good ways to show
love now I do agree that there are
certain gifts like oh you know while
so-and-so's wife was away at work the
husband stayed home and cleaned the
whole house and that was maybe a gift to
his wife I do understand that we can
give gifts that way but I would say that
that is is more of showing compassion
and showing support in addition to
giving a gift of time by cleaning the
house so I would just encourage your
boyfriend your family members to gift
experiences over things if they really
really want to spend some money on you
then maybe you can ask for some gift
cards - something that you're looking
for like I know one time I needed a
refrigerator for my my condo that I was
trying to sell so I went around on my
friends and family I'm like hey I need a
refrigerator for my condo I know
everyone here is gonna get me you know a
five or ten dollar trinket as a gift for
Christmas do you guys mind getting me a
Best Buy gift certificate and I got
about oh I don't know how many it was
but I got a bunch of gift certificates
and it didn't pay for the whole
refrigerator but it paid for like 30% of
it or 40% of it so so that was a huge
huge help to me everyone else felt good
they were able to get me a gift
there's no harm in asking for something
that you want I mean these these people
love you they want you to be happy they
want to support you so go out of your
way to tell them how they can support
you with the things that you have now I
mean my mother and I we have an
agreement if she gets me something that
doesn't add value then I will find
someone else who can get value out of
that item or I will find an organization
who will find someone else to get value
out of that I am an item I will go to a
goodwill and give away some stuff ID my
mom she visited me last year so this is
a year ago she brought me this like
beautiful owl vase and the
to candleholders and I open it up and
begin as soon as I open it up she's like
now I know that you may not like this
and it's okay if you know if you go and
donate it but I just wanted to bring you
a housewarming gift and you know what
the owl vase fit really well with what
we had so I put the owl of a SUP I still
have it um in fact when she was in town
last week she was talking about how
happy she was that that I had a gift of
hers displayed in my home and it made
her really really happy and those two
candle holders well I went and I donated
those and my mother because she does
love me and she does want to support me
she didn't give me a hard time about the
candle holders she understood that those
were two items that she found beautiful
but I I didn't necessarily and she was
okay with that these are not easy
conversations to have for for everyone
out there um you know Courtney that's
not an easy conversation to have but
these are conversations that must be had
and I think when you're having these
conversations you know it's it's
important to start the conversation in a
very positive light but also to keep as
much negative emotion out of it so even
if even if someone does get a little
offended when you bring up this
conversation it is important to not
react to that too to show as much
compassion to show as much love put
yourself in their shoes and then react
to maybe a negative reaction from a
family member because once they see that
you are being genuine once they see that
you're coming from a place of compassion
and love the chances are they're going
to start coming from that place as well
all right Courtney I am going to send
you a copy of our book essential I think
there's a lot of good advice on there
how to keep a balance between this gift
giving and gift receiving all right our
next voice mail is from Charlene as far
as from my mortgage I pay off all my
debt a few months ago and have just
recently chosen to leave my well-paying
corporate job in order to pursue some
kind of work that is more meaningful to
me the problem is I don't have a clear
picture about what I want to do
I know I'll be able to survive on
savings for a little while but
eventually I will need to resume
collecting some kind of income so my
question is do you have any tips for
someone in my situation or a pitfall
that I should be looking out for I would
be interested in hearing your
experiences from when you left your last
job
Sharleen paid off all your debt
congratulations that is awesome man I I
just became debt free for the first time
last year and it is the most freeing
feeling I have ever had I am I'm gonna
stay out of debt for as long as I can
I I refuse to go into debt for anything
right now there may be a time in the
future when that is a tool that I might
need to utilize but I really really hope
that I'm able to stay out of debt the
rest of my life so congratulations there
Charlene that is an amazing
accomplishment when I was in the
corporate world and got laid off
strategically what I mean by
strategically as I sat my boss down one
day and I said hey I got a question for
you man
if if I left one one day if I leave here
in the future and he knew that about our
website he knew that I was kind of
looking to make a change so you know if
I ever do decide to make this change who
are you going to replace me with let's
talk about my replacement and he looked
at me he was like you know I don't think
I would replace you because I was hired
to open up this small office/home office
business sales channel and a bunch of
retail stores and I did that and I did
it well and it was it was going so well
that that they really didn't need me to
run it anymore because the support was
there in place and everyone was trained
to do their job so when he said I don't
think I would replace you I kind of
looked out of them and I'm like huh
that's an interesting thought and a
couple months later he called me into
the office and I was laid off but but
yeah going from moving a hundred miles
an hour to a complete stop it was so it
was
so jarring i had no idea how jarring it
was going to be I literally remember
when I got laid off I had about I don't
know probably 30 emails sitting in my
inbox that I hadn't read there was a few
in there that I had to that I had read
needed to respond to there was all these
projects I had going on my phone was
ringing nonstop and then as soon as I
got laid off and walked out of that
office all of it just went away and and
that would be the first first tip that I
kind of give you Charlene is be prepared
for that that that very quick stop have
have a plan I really wish I would have
had a better plan for when I got laid
off I was thinking that well once I get
laid off I'll be able to do whatever I
want I'll be able to get up and read if
I want I'll be able to get up and write
if I want or I'll just be able to get up
and and veg on some Netflix if I want
and I'll tell you doing it as I as I
just went along was very very very
detrimental that first month I got very
little writing done I got very little
reading done because I was just kind of
winging it and it wasn't until I really
started incorporating a good schedule it
wasn't until I really started getting
more productive and and feeling better
about myself so I I don't have a routine
I don't have you know I I mean I have a
routine in the sense of I'll get up at 7
o'clock
pretty much every day if it's not seven
it'll be eight o'clock and then I'm
usually in bed by 10:00 p.m. or 11:00
p.m. at night I focus on three things
every single day I focus on eating well
I focus on moving well and then I get as
much sleep as I can so those are kind of
like the three three ingredients for me
that that I guess I incorporated into my
everyday life but there is not a
specific routine that I have revolved
around that I will typically plan out my
weeks so on Sunday night I will look at
my week and and plan out my week a
quarter
so if I'm looking at okay Tuesday's
that's when we record podcasts that's
when we have you know our our meeting to
catch up on whatever but Wednesday I've
got open and Thursday I've got open okay
well Wednesday and Thursday uh you know
I'm going to do these three or four
things and I will put that in my
schedule so that would be my first my
first tip for you is if you leave your
corporate job make sure that you have
have a plan to act on what went when you
leave there especially when it comes to
your routine the other thing too is once
you leave your job don't be fooled that
you're gonna find this perfect job where
you wake up every single morning elated
I know that we talk about job versus
career versus mission and even when
we're living our mission even when we're
doing the things that we love to do
there's still a lot of work involved and
I think I underplayed that I knew there
was some work to do but I wasn't really
honest with myself on how much work
there was going to be ahead of me now
the difference between me working a lot
now and me working a lot six years ago
is now the work that I put into
everything aligns with my values and
beliefs it the outcome that I get is is
far greater than the outcome I used to
get six years ago so that's really what
I focus on is my outcome so I guess I'm
giving you this advice because let's say
that you quit your job and you want to
start developing a good exercise routine
and you want to be a personal trainer
I'm just throwing this out there there's
a lot of work that goes into that now
the results are going to be amazing
you're gonna be fit you're gonna be
healthy you're gonna show other people
how to be healthy but it's gonna take a
lot of work to get there so my
recommendation is whatever you choose to
do when you leave work focus on that
outcome focus on on on what you
ultimately want to get and then the
other piece of that too is and I'm kind
of going off of the ultimate
success formulator witch Josh and I talk
about all the time we got that from Tony
Robbins but not only think about the
outcome but think about why you want
that outcome what are the reasons behind
you wanting to have this final outcome
why do you want to be a I'll just stick
with the the example of a personal
trainer why do you want to be a personal
trainer well it's because I want to show
other people how to get fit I want to be
fit myself I want to add a lot of value
whatever the reasons are be clear on
those because that is what is going to
help you keep that motivation to move
forward but expect to have your Peaks in
your valleys and when you're at the peak
enjoy it and when you're in the valley
push through and Drudge through that
drudgery another thing I'll say to
Sharlene is don't don't look at the
passion that you cultivate don't look at
that as a way to make money I mean if
anything if you are concerned about
providing yourself with an income after
you leave your job because certainly you
said you didn't have savings that was
gonna last you for the rest of your life
it'll last you a little bit you don't
want to just burn through that savings I
would encourage you to find a a
part-time job or even if it is a
full-time job that's fine but fine to
find a job that aligns with your values
and beliefs I mean when I got laid off I
had about six months worth of bills
saved up between my savings and a little
bit of severance that I had and I told
myself that if I didn't have a clear
plan on how I was gonna pay my bills
after those six months if I didn't have
a clear plan after the first month or
two I was gonna go get a job as a
barista and it's not because I look at
being a barista as like that's my
passion as much as being a barista
aligns with my values and beliefs it
aligns with it just aligns with how I
want to live my life it would allow me
to have time each day each week to
invest in my health to invest into my
relationships to cultivate a passion to
grow to contribute so I would encourage
you to if you're worried about paying
your bills
find a job that aligns with your values
and beliefs well first you need to get
clear on what your values and beliefs
are but after you do that then find a
job that aligns with those and any
passion that you cultivate do that do
that on the side don't don't just pick
something as soon as you leave work to
say well this is what I'm gonna make
money out because that's not always
going to be a guarantee all right
Charlene thank you for that question I'm
going to send you a copy of everything
that remains that is the non fictional
narrative that Josh and I wrote about
when we left the corporate world it's
actually a narrative through Josh's eyes
on his transition from the corporate
world to ultimately being a minimalist
and in Montana so I think that'll help
you because it goes into detail with our
transitions all right our next voicemail
is from John my question is concerning
their two dogs lately they're not
bringing any value to our life in fact
they are complicating things but it goes
against my personal belief system too to
not take personal responsibility for of
life that you have committed to so I
want to know what what are some options
I should have and what are some things
that you would recommend as far as the
situation and also we're going to be
moving into a 228 square foot home so
we're also not gonna really have a lot
of room in addition to the fact that
they are adding any value to our lives
John you want to minimize your dogs yeah
I I agree with you 100% man those are
lives that you brought in to your life I
mean be the same thing if you had kids
right I mean you wouldn't just be like
well these kids aren't really adding any
value I'm gonna go you know put them off
at the adoption center I I feel the same
way um I actually went through this when
I was living in Ohio
I had a cat his name was O'Malley he was
an awesome cat he still is an awesome
cat I would basically go on these little
stents where Josh and I would you know
go on tour for a couple weeks or maybe
we go to a speaking engagement or
whatever it may be
I found myself leaving at least once a
month or once every other month for a
week or two at a time and as this was
going on I noticed the deterioration of
my my cat's attitude he he would get
really upset with me I would always
bring him down to my mom's she would
watch him for the time that I was gone
then I'd go pick him up and bring him
back but it seemed like every single
time I did that it was just getting
worse and worse and he was becoming more
and more miserable so I kind of faced
the same situation where I'm like shoot
like I really need to find this cat a
good home because he's not very happy
here so I put the word out I I talked to
my girlfriend at the time I talked to
friends I talked to family put put
messages out on Facebook and it took me
about six weeks but I was eventually
able to find a home for O'Malley it was
a it was my girlfriend's at the time it
was my girlfriend at the time it was her
friends who were looking for a cat and
it just happened to be a great situation
they have sent me pictures and videos of
him him playing with with their other
cat and with their their little baby and
and it's wonderful to get those updates
so that's that's that's the approach
that I took that is the approach that I
would encourage you to take I mean I
know that there are like no kill animal
shelters out there that you could
potentially bring them to personally I
couldn't do that
I'm not gonna judge anyone who does that
I'm certain there are situations out
there where that is the best option but
it sounds like you got a little bit of
time so just put some legwork into it
man Facebook Craigslist your friends
your family your co-workers really go
out of your way to find these dogs a
good home I certainly wouldn't encourage
you to just drop them off at a shelter
it's a good question
I know that this answer is a little
simple but that doesn't make it easy
it's gonna be a lot of work to find a
home for those dogs I'm gonna send you a
copy of minimalism live and meaningful
life John minimalism live a meaningful
life is the first book Josh and I wrote
where we really talk about our values
and beliefs and I think with any
decision we make in life whether it's
with bringing in a physical item whether
it's committing to a new job or new
hobby or whatever it may be a new
relationship we really need to look at
our values and beliefs
so hopefully this book will help you
make some you know different decisions
in the future and maybe look a little
bit farther ahead for when you want to
maybe bring another animal into your
life or maybe a kid or something like
that so we'll send you a copy of live a
meaningful life John thank you very much
for that question we'd love to hear what
all of you have to say so if you have a
comment about today's podcast or if
you've got a minimalism tip that you
really find beneficial in your life then
leave us a voicemail at four zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine weal
air our favorite comments and tips on
the next episode and if your voicemail
is selected we'll send you an
autographed copy of one of our books
either essential or minimalism live a
meaningful life or everything that
remains now we're gonna move on to our
iTunes comment of the week
this one is brought to you by sand
dramedy sand drama DS title of their
comment is life-changing that's with the
next elimination mark super excited to
start my new life each podcast is adding
so much value I never thought that less
stuff was the key to my true happiness
I'm becoming a better mom and person
thanks to you both for being an
inspiration and thanks for teaching me
the true art of contentment minimalism
Thank You San dramedy for that lovely
comment I am going to send you two
tickets to our upcoming documentary
minimalism a documentary about the
important
things that airs on May 24th
I'm sorry debuts airs it's not airing
yet it's just debuting in theaters on
May 24th but no I think you'll like that
documentary a lot if you enjoy listening
to me and Josh you know two to two guys
with no kids if you enjoy listening to
us talk about minimalism you're gonna
love listening to a whole whole lot of
other people with diverse viewpoints on
minimalism talk about it we've got
minimalist families we've got minimalist
architects there's there's a lot of a
lot of good information there so I think
you will find some additional value too
and thank you to everyone else who has
left a review on iTunes you're positive
honest reviews helped our simple living
message reach more ears so keep them
coming we'll keep reading our favorite
iTunes comments on the podcast so feel
free to get extra creative with your
comments okay you guys know what time it
is it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round
yeah where we answer questions from
social media we're on Twitter and
Instagram at the minimalists and
facebook.com slash the minimalists our
first question is from Jana Jana writes
how do you combat procrastination trying
to minimize my things but it's taking me
a long time no momentum well with
anything in life where we feel
overwhelmed it's an it's very important
that we we don't take it all on at once
so I don't know exactly how cluttered
your life is with physical possessions
Jana but if it's a lot if you're looking
at a cluttered and a completely
cluttered house where every room has
clutter and it starts small start with
your your bedroom closet or your
bathroom linen closet and just focus on
one area every single week focus on one
small area I mean there's that that's
saying that we've all heard you don't
eat an elephant all at once you have to
take it one bite at a time
this goes with a lot of things in life
and definitely with our material
possessions when they become too
overwhelming I mean for me it was about
having a packing party where I packed up
all my belongings as if I were moving
and then I unpacked things as I needed
it over the next three weeks for me I
had to do something very extreme because
I know that for me the only way that I
can get anything done especially when I
find myself stuck in a runt or not being
able to keep up momentum is I will do
something extreme to change my state so
whatever you need to do to change your
state do that Jana but don't overwhelm
yourself too much you could do a packing
party like I did if you find it easier
to do it that way a lot of people they
think of a packing party in it and it
sends them heading for the hills which I
completely understand if if that's too
overwhelming then start with a packing
party in just a small room but the key
here is to form a plan and to stick to
it don't have too full of a plate
I'll tell you what helps me to is having
an accountability partner Mariah does a
really good job of this
I talk to her often about okay this is
what I want to do this week and if you
see me kind of slacking off a little bit
do you mind giving me a little elbow in
the ribs or do you mind
you know maybe mentioning something here
there and she does it in a very loving
way a very kind way she doesn't have to
remind me all the time but there are
times when she's like oh where are you
gonna go ahead and take care of this
today so we could you know do this
tomorrow and I'm like oh yeah that's
right I did say that so having an
accountability partner will definitely
help in that situation just find a
friend or a family member
significant other to to come over and
help you a declutter that closet or
maybe maybe they come over and help you
a declutter two closets whatever it may
be form a plan and if you think it'll
help find an accountability partner
who's willing to help you out and Jana
I'll tell you what helps me to is you
know not just finding an accountability
partner or accountability person I will
also try and find a mentor I can tell
you there are a ton of mentors I have
had in my life so if you can't find an
accountability partner or you can't find
a mentor you can always go to the
minimalists com forward slash mentoring
where I do offer some mentoring services
now I'm booked out until after the tour
until June but I've got a whole team of
mentors there that are ready to help
others out and help hold them
accountable it was funny when I first
started the the mentoring thing I I was
just doing it myself and there would be
times where I would go take a question
from a client or a student I like to say
I guess clients probably uh I don't like
using that word anymore so I would take
a question from a student and go ask one
of my mentors hey I just had this great
question from a student like what would
you tell them and then I'm like wait a
minute
why am I being the middleman here I'm
just going to I'm just going to give
access to everyone to - or to the people
who I find to be really good mentors so
feel free to check that out for anyone
out there who is looking for
accountability a partner I can't find
one we would be happy to help provide
you one now I know that you're thinking
that Ryan he's just trying to sell us as
mentoring services and yeah I am trying
to provide a service here but you know
if you don't need a mentor than great
don't worry about it don't don't go
check it out
but at the end of the day Josh and I we
don't recommend anything that we don't
find true valuing there are a ton of
good mentors there I've got one
gentleman who has experience and running
a multi-billion dollar business I've got
an awesome team of people who do great
graphic design work and website building
I've got a dating coach
if you're having trouble meeting people
I have someone who will coach you
through your writing in the writing
process and in just the artistic process
in general so there's a ton of resources
there if you find yourself needing
needing that check it out if not then
don't check it out that's alright our
next question is from Aaron Aaron writes
is there value and missing a loved one
who lives far away what feelings and
emotions don't add value well I would
certainly say that missing a loved one I
don't know if that adds value but it is
an emotion that we all experience so
this this feeling of longing to see
someone I don't know if that is an
emotion that someone can just completely
block out now I do know that there is a
point of useless rumination my my family
was just here last week they're gone
they're back in Ohio I miss them already
but I don't sit around every single
second of the day and ruminate on how
much I miss them I know that it's
important for me to think about them
it's important for me to keep a pulse on
how my relationship is going with my
friends and family but I don't i do not
practice useless rumination so i think
that is where this feeling of missing a
loved one i
think that is where it would be it would
be pointless is to just sit there and
and ruminate on it for no reason I mean
you asked too about what feelings and
emotions don't add value I would say
jealousy is one of those emotions that
doesn't add value there is not one good
reason I can think of where the emotion
of jealousy adds value now do I get
jealous
sure I get jealous but every time I get
jealous I have to ask myself why am i
jealous am i jealous because my pride is
hurt because my ego is hurt and I really
have to face that emotion head-on and
certainly jealousy the more we ruminate
on that the the more egregious actions I
guess we would take maybe not egregious
it certainly could to lead to an
egregious action but ruminating on on on
jealousy is not going to do us any good
same thing with hate I think hate is
another one of those now people are
gonna say well sometimes you gotta hate
something and I don't think you ever
have to hate anything like let's look at
you know pointless pointless crimes
pointless murders or starvation with
kids I mean those are all things that
that that I hate now you know when I
think about governments and other
countries who are intentionally starving
their population I really hate that but
that hate isn't going to do me any good
the only thing that's gonna do good in
that situation is action now that hate
might drive me towards some type of
action to assist those in need but I
would still argue that it wasn't the
hate that drove me it was more of the
compassion that drove me to take an
action to help someone in need so these
are all emotions that we all experience
they're not easy to control but if we do
take some time to really tackle those
emotions head-on they're a lot easier to
deal with rather than just going with a
feeling and
and just acting on it because it feels
good to act on that feeling our next
question is from Jordan Jordan writes
why the uniform black t-shirt jeans and
brown boots I love it and find it
interesting
people always want to know about my
black t-shirts I'll tell you why I have
a uniform it's because I feel like I
look good in it when I look in the
mirror I'm like all right I look
presentable today and that makes me feel
good it also helps me eliminate at least
you know 3 I'd say 3 or 4 decisions in
the morning there is this whole study
around how many good decisions we get to
make in a day I think it's like around
150 or 200 like you basically are able
to make 150 to 200 good decisions a day
before you experienced decision fatigue
so getting up and having my outfit
already picked out every single day
helps me to avoid this decision fatigue
in fact I was reading this article where
Obama was talking about how he doesn't
pick out of suits he doesn't pick out
his breakfast because he understands
that there is this thing called decision
fatigue and every time we have to make a
decision we exhaust ourselves a little
bit so I would say that is probably one
of the biggest reasons why I have the
same uniform every single day is because
it allows me to make other decisions
that that need my attention not just
decisions but good decisions by the way
I read in the New York Times somewhere
that we make 35,000 decisions a day what
are you gonna eat we're gonna go to next
we're gonna walk we're gonna put on
where you're gonna brush your teeth
today you're gonna brush them again at
night I mean there's just all these
different decisions we make every single
day and some studies have shown that we
have to make up to 35,000 now if we only
get 150 to 200 good decisions a day it's
important that we we limit as many
decisions as possible if you want to
find out more about decision fatigue you
just google it there are so many
different articles out there we can we
can post one article in the show notes
I'll give to you Shawn to put in there
from the New York Times it was an
article from a few years ago but but
very very good article on on what
decision fatigue is Maxine Maxine asks
one will I be able to call myself a
minimalist and truly be in tune with all
it offers whoa Maxine you have to own
exactly 52 things and if you have a
child you can own another 23 things and
if that child if it's a girl actually
you can own 20 28 things no I know
Maxine I wish there was some magic
recipe some you know a number of things
that was perfect for every single person
in every single situation and the
reality is is there is no end game to
minimalism you know I wasn't a
minimalist until I called myself a
minimalist until Josh and I bought the
domain for seven bucks with the
minimalists you know we weren't
minimalists so deciding I think is what
really makes you a minimalist and then
every single day it's it's asking
yourself that question of is this going
to add value to my life with with every
single resource that we have whether
it's our time whether it's our money and
now you know I'm not perfect I don't I
don't make a hundred percent good
decisions every single day but I will
say that working these habits into my
everyday life practicing this philosophy
of simplicity has helped me to to really
focus on on those three things that I
talked about earlier eating while
sleeping well moving around getting some
exercise I'm able to focus on what
brings me joy and it takes work so when
will you be able to call yourself a
minimalist today Maxine you can call
yourself a minimalist today all right
Julia writes what would a minimalist put
inside a time capsule Julia I don't
think I would ever have a time capsule
seriously though I was talking to Sean
about this before our producer I was
talking to him about what we would put
in time capsule and I'm like there
really is nothing I might have a time
capsule flashdrive maybe maybe that's
what I would have but
but other than that I can't think of any
physical items I think would be super
important for us to to carry through or
to look at you know fifty years or a
hundred years from now I mean when we
think about time capsules anyway its
novelty why don't we ever when have we
ever opened up a time capsule when we
were like oh my god we totally forgot
that this existed fifty years ago and
it's gonna make a huge difference to us
right now no it's it's usually some kind
of nostalgic reminiscing it's it's a
novelty it's a novelty thing and and you
know when it comes down to it
I leave it up to the experts to decide
what's important to preserve whether
it's a museum curator or someone who
specializes in antiques you know I leave
those decisions up to up to the
professionals all right our last
question for hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round is from mark mark writes
what would you tell your 18 year old
self oh man I don't know I probably just
shake the crap out of them you know I
think I think my first bit of advice to
my 18 year old self would be people
first money second and what I mean by
that is is is I was so focused on how
much money I was making so I could
accumulate as many things as I wanted
that I was putting people aside and now
it's the opposite now money is the
opportunity cost I'm not saying that you
know Josh and I are allergic to money or
that we don't make any money or we don't
need money that's not the case but we
don't make decisions solely based on
money the first question we will ask is
you know how is this going to affect our
audience how is this gonna make our
audience feel how is this gonna make us
feel how is this gonna make the people
who are important to us how is it going
to make them feel how is it gonna affect
them and then we can look at the okay
this is what it's gonna cost if we
decide to do this this is what it's
going to cost us so that would probably
probably be the the first bit of advice
and then like I said I would probably
just shake myself and and really try to
get myself to understand that all those
things that I desire it's not it's not
what's gonna lead me to happiness
it's not going to lead me to having a
good standing in society and I was very
caught up on the car I drove the house I
had that's what was gonna make me you
know be have a good standing in the
society around me and and there's just
not the case
I probably tell myself to stop doing
drugs too because that was I mean when I
was 18 not that I was doing a ton of
drugs when I was 18 but just kind of
occasionally but that led up to very
heavy usage in my early to mid 20s and I
really really wish I would have just
stopped when I was 18 because the longer
I had went on the harder it was to to
stop doing those things so there's
that's probably the advice I would I
would give it my 18 year old self
alright now it is time for our added
value portion of the show where we
recommend something that has added value
to us in our lives recently I'm gonna
recommend a podcast I was listening to
yesterday I was listening to a podcast
called the good life toasted by
gentleman named Jonathan Fields and he
was interviewing a guy named chase
Jarvis this was a podcast from a couple
months ago but I was just kind of
getting caught up I'm so glad that I
went into the archive and found this
specific podcast it did a really good
job of talking about how to cultivate
your passion and cultivate your work and
really find something meaningful to put
your time and energy into and and make a
living from it but then they also
touched on how to plan for what was next
and how to kind of cultivate something
else I'm gonna do a very bad job of
paraphrasing this that's why we're gonna
put this link up on the show notes so
you guys can listen to yourself but one
of the biggest takeaways I had from this
podcast was them talking about how yes
we have our main work we have we have
what we do with the majority of our day
and then there are these hobbies there
there are these passions that we are
cultivating on the side when that
happens and
instead of looking at you know how am I
going to leave what I'm currently doing
instead it's it's more of a focus on
okay these side hobbies these things
that I'm working on in my spare time
this is my next work this is actually
what I am going to do next and when I
think about how Josh and I have evolved
over the last six years with the
minimalists comm it did it started out
it started out one way and it has
evolved since and just you know one of
the side things I can think about that
Josh and I've been working on that are
now coming to fruition is our
documentary you know we didn't we did
not go into this documentary thinking
okay alright well we need a we need a
good revenue source for uh 2016 let's go
ahead and film a documentary that is not
how we approach that we approached our
documentary as something that we thought
we could try and do we had a very
creative director Matt D Avella who was
willing to try it out with us and to see
what we could come up with and we you
know we didn't have any expectations but
now it's something that has completely
exceeded any expectations like I could
have had and I'm really excited about it
and again that just kind of started off
as a side project and now you know we've
got this documentary that's that's an
amazing film and we're really excited to
to get it out there yeah so go check out
Jonathan fields good life project I
think you'll find a lot of value in it
especially that podcast episode where he
interviews Chase Jarvis again that will
be in our show notes if you want to
check that out all right guys I'm gonna
move on to our next segment which we
call right here right now it's where we
get to talk about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalists of course you
know about our documentary you can go to
minimalism film calm where you can see
the trailer and if you'd like to see the
film just click see the film that comes
out on May 24th I just want to reiterate
guys you can't wait until the night of
to buy tickets to this you got to get
them in advance so if you want to see
our documentary please please go there
and get some tickets we also have
tuesdays with the minimalists on
periscope and Twitter we are doing that
through the rest of April and then it's
done so you still have a
chance to catch Josh and I live really
it's just an excuse for us to get on
periscope and be goofy and you know it's
it's like deleted after 24 hours so we
can get away with a lot on there of
course Josh has his class how to write
better which is on June 26 you can go to
how to write better dot-org if you want
to find out more about that I have taken
Josh's writing class and it it's a great
great class to take if you're looking to
form habits Josh does a really good job
of laying out how he writes what his
process is he shows you his recipe now
that recipe is not very easy to imitate
but I promise you that there are a few
ingredients there that you will take
away from it if you're someone who is
just wanting to get in to writing but
don't really know where to start that's
a great class and then of course guys
there's always minimalist org if you
find yourself and eating some support or
if you want to support others in their
journey with simplicity then go to
minimalist or we've got a hundred cities
around the world where people are
meeting up each month and they're doing
different stuff some some cities will go
on tiny home tours some cities will talk
about budgeting or they'll bring in a
budgeting expert but there's always a
lot going on there if you go to
minimalist Oregon you do not find a city
near you you can always go to our online
city where you will also find a ton of
support and finally here are some
voicemail comments from our listeners hi
this is Andrew Meade from Philadelphia
and I had a few comments about the
careers episode which just aired a one
caller called in and they said their
biggest barrier to entry in terms of
switching from a full-time job to their
own career is health insurance and that
was definitely something that I've
struggled with as well and I just wanted
to point out a tool it's called stride
health STR IDE health.com
I'm not affiliated in any way I've just
been a customer for a year and it is
fantastic they hook you up with a really
easy way to get insurance through
unitedhealthcare
you don't have to go through any of the
boring paperwork that you would if you
went through them directly strike a few
simple forms you fill out
it's truly fantastic another comment I
had about another caller was that she
said she was not basically passionate
about a lot of different things and she
found that every few months she switched
her passions and that she was getting
discouraged because she always switched
to different things and one comment I'd
like to leave is if you love learning
teach I mean you can be surprised how
much you know after just a couple months
of learning something that someone who's
getting into the basics won't now you
can offer a lot of value teaching the
things you just learned so that's always
an option - hi this is Anna from
Columbia Maryland responding to the most
recent episode of the podcast really
little bit podcast by the way about
traveling I came across a website called
go eco and I haven't been on one of
their trips but if you look at travel
instead of drying sizing and stuff and
you look at it instead in terms of like
volunteering and then getting to see
some new places and people along the way
then you can save a lot of money that I
think the goat eco that org trips are
really reasonable and I think there's
other organizations that are similar
hello my name is Annie and I'm calling
from Los Angeles California
I just finished our sentimental podcast
and wanted to share what helps me
declutter my sentimental items
it might sound morbid but I'd like to
think about if I were to pass away all
of a sudden how would I feel about my
family and friends looking through all
my stuff when I want them to find all
those unflattering middle-school photos
or read all the immature sauce I wrote
down in my high school journal probably
not so when I think about how
embarrassed I would be if they came
across these items
it makes me extra motivated to get rid
of them now since life is short and we
don't really know when it's going to be
our last day and when talking things out
all at once is too difficult I find it
helpful to do it in rounds for instance
i declutter old mutters multiple times
but always had a hard time throwing away
thoughtful letters from old guy friends
or all
boyfriends even though I don't talk to
any of them anymore but after I got
married last year I realized that if I
were to pass away it would be my husband
sorting through these letters need to
know they don't say anything
incriminating I'm sure he would
appreciate me staring him the trouble by
getting rid of them now which is what I
did
so revisiting stuff you wanted to
clutter during a different season of
your life might just be the extra crush
that was needed to finally throw
something away hey guys this is Joe from
Maryland I just actually wanted to say
thank you for sending your message to
out onto the worlds everyone can learn
from you guys I actually got a ton out
of your message and I'm actually a
doctor a pediatrician and my current job
gets me a lot of good money but I'm
seeing up to 60 patients a day which is
about five to seven minutes per patient
and I'm really tired I'm really stressed
and overwhelmed and I also feel like I'm
not doing my patients justice I also
have been working a lot of late-night
hours till 10 p.m.
seeing patients and lots of weekends and
holidays and I haven't been seen my wife
is watching my family as much as I'd
like actually my wife is in a different
City because of both pursuing medical
careers and I'm making good money but
I'm basically unhappy not seeing my
family in life not doing my patients
justice and being tired after he heard
TED talks and listen to podcasts and
minimalizing a lot I've actually decided
I've actually got interviews to get a
job in my wife city which is part-time
pediatrics where I'll get to spend a lot
more time with each patient
I'll get time for myself to take care of
my health and the money is less but it's
better for my wife for my patients and
for me and to me I'm incredibly excited
for this possibility and even if I don't
get this job I'm going to keep applying
for jobs that are like it all right so
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for
minimalists give us a call at four zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
and if you leave here with just one
message I hope it's this love people and
use things because the opposite never
works thanks for listening y'all we'll
see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
feeling that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine
but I
you